Speaker 1: I am seriously going to suggest
that you first watch or listen to this segment
before letting children hear it, because it's
that disturbing.
I'm just putting it out there.
I want to tell you, I'm about to play a clip
that is extraordinarily disturbing.
This might be the most disturbing Christian
sex story of all time.
This was unearthed by Hemant Mehta.
Who writes the friendly atheist Substack is
really good.
I follow him on Twitter.
Okay, I am going to play a video for you here
where Dr. Glenn Hill and his wife, Phyllis
Hill, were interviewed by pro abstinence girl
defined cohost Bethany Biehl.
In this interview.
I I'm sorry that we I just have to explain
it in this way.
There aren't there almost aren't words enough
to describe what happens here.
The wife of the couple.
Ms.. Hill describes that for a long time.
She believed she had no clitoris.
And she.
Oh, my God.
She only found out specifically what it is
when her friend showed her on her baby girl.
I've never seen anything like this.
Okay.
Look.
Look at this.
Speaker 3: Like, I was like, Yeah, I'm broken.
Like, I didn't even think that that was a
weird sentence.
But she said, Okay, what can you define broken?
What?
What are you saying?
What does that mean?
And then I just said, Oh, well, I don't have
a clitoris.
Because at this point, Glenn, it read enough
to know that a clitoris was involved and yeah,
didn't.
Speaker 1: Know where he was as clueless as
I was.
But once he accidentally stumbled upon an
issue of the New England Medical Journal and.
Speaker 3: Was but knew that that mattered
and that had to do with an orgasm.
And it's like I've never orgasmed and there's
no pleasure.
I don't enjoy it.
Matter of fact, I hate it.
I just endure it.
We just get through it as fast as possible.
And, and so, yeah, we shared that openly.
And she was in the medical field and she was
like, Okay, well, what do you mean you don't
have a clitoris?
Speaker 4: And our friend after a bit said,
You know, I just feel like taking pills in
the back room is showing her what I'm talking
about.
Well, so it started to stand up.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 5: And then this other woman said,
I just can't.
I can't do that.
Our oldest child had been born, which a little
girl and eventually tell us is changing our
daughter's diaper.
And our friend showed her on our little girl.
You know where the clitoris is located, which
is huge information.
Speaker 4: Well, privileged.
And again, it's stunning to me.
That's pretty darn basic, folks.
Speaker 1: This is the moral majority, right?
Or something like that.
This is I mean, cringe doesn't cover it.
This.
This is just.
I'm struggling to find the words and maybe
a different language would better have the
words for this.
But I'm struggling to find the words to explain
and understand this bizarre turn.
Now, this video since Hemant found it.
It was set to private.
And it looks like they're trying to kind of
scrub this because this is so completely insane
now.
Glen Hill.
Is a, quote, clinical sexologist.
That's what he describes himself as.
Apparently with a Ph.D..
How do these things happen?
What is happening here where the people.
Speaker 4: Least able.
Speaker 1: To actually work through and understand
and explain also, I mean, listen to sexual
dysfunction and of lack of sex said all these
different things, you know.
And these are the folks that say we are the
ones who can explain to you the right how
things work and the right and this it's borderline.
You should just check in with Child Protective
Services.
And clearly, they recognize that they're trying
to scrub this video.
It it it has just it has creepy all over it.
It has creepy all over it.
And you don't have to think that anything
inappropriate was going on with a baby to
just see this and go, oh, it's just I'm cringing.
It just doesn't feel right what's going on
here?
And they are now doing everything they can
to make sure that this stuff is all removed.
We may get hit with some kind of copyright
violation for even surfacing this.
I'll keep you posted if indeed that happens.
But really, really vile stuff.
Quick break.
Back after this.
The David Pakman Show depends on your support.
We have a membership program which you can
sign up for it.
Join Packman dot com.
It includes the show we do every day with
no commercials made available to you hours
earlier than we publish it to everybody else,
as well as a daily bonus show and extra show
where we talk about more a news stories, analysis
and a lot of crazy things happen on that bonus
show you can sign up at Join Pacman dot com.
You
can use the coupon code indicted.
You can also use the coupon code indicated
either one will work.
The discounts are slightly different at join
pacman dot com